what do you have to do
copy and paste
[Music]
for those of you who don't know my story
my name is evansville i look at the
opportunity last year october as i said
and at the time it was a very dark place
in my life
um i felt like everything was going
wrong um
i was living with my girlfriend um
i was living in a parent's house about
two years living in that single room and
every single day i keep selling the
dreams like one day maybe we'll get out
of here one day we'll have this nice
house one day one day one day and after
trying so many
you know different ways
after a while you lose credibility and
she was getting to that point where she
was like i don't really know that one is
gonna come and um and that was at the
tipping point but for me the final
little coffin was um
i was playing with my son jaden on a
sunday around a house and i was like you
know what do you want to be when you
grow up you know
and
he was very precise he said to me that
he wants to be a dentist i'm thinking
right dentists
like it's cool i mean you know we need
more dentists around i think like why so
why a dentist but then
afterwards i realized the reason why i
wanted to be a dentist was because his
mom's brother his uncle was a dentist
and he used to bring him on all this
latest you know excursions and by him
all the latest deeps and stuff
and um and for me that was the i think
that was the
that was the turning point when i
realized that evans you've got to do
something because you tell this boy all
the things that he wanted to do but he's
not listening
he needs to see you do it so that's the
one that's what i realized you need to
do something and so you know what it is
i draw the line in the sand i'm like i
go become somebody and i always say when
you
you know when you pray
you know god gives you an opportunity
and i gave you an opportunity i started
binging on you know all these successful
people i came across mr sunny i'm like
who's this loud enthusiastic guy on
youtube
and um and i was just drawn into him i
started binging on his videos
and i came across someone i came across
this you know this exact same trait i
came across the eviction
and
i said you know what it is you know i'm
gonna do this man i'm gonna do whatever
it takes and some of you guys have seen
my story but for those who haven't seen
it in the last you know 12 months it's
completely changed my life around the
last 12 months i've been over 100 000
pounds you know in property um without
even owning any one of them in the last
few months i mean i've changed from
leaving my girlfriend's living room to
be a nice fancy apartment in canada for
viewing london co-owned personal trainer
um i've now engaged my partner but the
most important thing over the last 12
months is now my son
i mean i mean guess what my son wants to
be like now guess who he wants to be
right now
and for me that's the biggest thing but
today i'm going to talk about me today's
about you guys some of you guys are
beautiful for the very first time some
of you are on the edge so i just wanted
to just come on and share
three of the most important things for
me when it comes to rents around that
really just completely uplifted my
return career
speaking to an agent for example it's a
different language to speak into a
landlord what do i mean when you speak
to a landlord right a landlord is used
to something like they used to
management agreement
why because it's the same agreement that
the estate agents give to them so they
understand the military agreement
but also when you speak to an agent if
you use the same terminology they don't
think like you want to replace it like
why would i you know give you is the
same contract i got the landlord so the
language is very very important i mean
just imagine right
just imagine that you're going to a bar
right and you see this hottie man this
girl's at the bar and um you know you
approach this girl she's a little bit
thick but it'll be in the stomach
and um i like your approach oh my god
you're so beautiful
how many months pregnant are you
can you agree guys by eraser finds that
her right hand is going to end up on
your on your electricity by subway
shipping can you agree with that yeah
yeah now can you agree that it doesn't
matter how many bars you go to how many
different seas how many different
countries it doesn't matter what
language the girl speaks as long as
you're telling her about she's gonna how
many months is due because it's not
gonna work
yeah so that's the reason why when you
come to the trade a lot of people say go
for no you can go for more as much as
you want but if you send the wrong
things to the agent or the landlord
you're never gonna get a deal
so for those of you coming to the train
you're going to learn the exact menu the
exact recipe that i learned the exact
word about what to say
even if my caribbean accent can get
there if you learn those terminology and
rent around you're going to kill it the
second thing i need to know which is
very very important write this down this
one is very extremely i think is the
most important one and if you guys get
this one
everything's going to
change for you
control
what's the word guys
that's very very important man
control is everything and what exactly
do i mean by control when you're
speaking to
anybody right preferably agents or
landlords you need to be in control
because if you're not in control
you're not in a position to close them
and
one of the keys that there is for
control is asking questions
and when i first came on the rent to
rent and him a boot camp
i learned again like you've got to play
this game this game is absolutely
amazing it's a game called questions
right
you have to answer every question
but also ask a question at the end of it
and if you want to control the
conversation that's one of the most
important things whoever asked if
there's one thing that you guys heard
from me today is that whoever asked the
most questions is in control very very
very important man
the last thing is which which leads to
this if you don't get control the last
one you're not going to get it right
right and this is the most important one
of all of it
close it guys what's the word
you have to close man a lot of people
are afraid of being closed you know
they've got this misconception about
selling about closing but everything
that you do in life is closing like just
imagine man like
is anybody in there mario doing a
relationship by raising hands
yeah all right so all the single guys
look at each other
is the hands
but if you've got a partner or you've
never had a partner i presume all of you
have
you all have sold to them
can you guys agree yeah
same thing so don't expect to go to an
agent using the right scripts asking
questions and not you have to close them
you have to close them and you have to
have a specific structure like when you
get on the phone your goal is to get
into the property that's your goal don't
try and close them over the phone you
get in there you speak to them you pitch
to them you walk away but you have to
obviously always close this like the
three most important things guys that
that for me when i got started in
property that really just blew
everything for me i came to the train i
learned what to say
i learned about you know asking
questions that changed everything even
at home
i even got a ring on my partner's finger
just by changing my game control very
very important and i learned how to
close right so that's very very very
important what do you have to do
copy and paste
this is me you have to copy and paste
guys one of the quickest ways of me
getting hey just copy and paste on your
list copying and pasting ricky i even
copy and paste them so much i copied it
a couple of things
no i say copy and paste you have to be
very selective
about who you copy
right because if i ask if i ask you guys
in the room right now how many of you
guys want to be financially free
popularization right all of you right
now what really frustrates me is that if
you you ask someone
if they want to you know if they want to
do something if they want somebody's end
result if they want somebody with
enemies they all say yes but the biggest
frustrating thing for me is that they're
willing to they want his end result
they're not willing to implement the
things that he's doing that you have to
do today to get to where he wants to go
to for me that's very very mind-boggling
never again can you ever tell honestly
tell someone that you never had a chance
to become somebody because property is
for everybody it's equal no one cares
about your age your size your race we
all go through the same training in
january we're gonna go for the same
training we haven't got one for doctors
and one no everybody come for the same
class everybody goes through the same
training and the difference from the
winners to the to the losers i mean i
don't need to insert anybody but
the difference between those on the
winners on the wednesday and those that
don't do anything and complain is the
right knowledge the right level of
belief copying and pasting and taking
action and i in closing all i want to
say is i really want to thank you guys
for taking the opportunity to listen to
me um listen to my story and i really
appreciate each and every one of you
guys
[Music]